bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
à 6 ans par les sports vous connaissez
désormais le programme est je le
rappelle pour les nouveaux
téléspectateurs il y aura des coups de
gueule des analyses des débats et des
duels et tout cela sur l'actualité
sportive du département
présentation de nos supers chroniqueur
en musique on commence à droite avec
notre spécialiste rugby et entraîne les
bélascain les moins de 21 ans du rugby
club de versailles c'est un mordu du
ballon ovale et des joutes du
département je veux bien sûr parler de
guillaume neyreneuf vous avez bien
guillaume très bien me diane merci à
vous monter en puissance au fur et à
mesure des émissions
oui oui tout à fait on va commencer à
vendre sans salaire le en forme on passe
à gauche musique il ya dujarrier vice
champion du monde de cyclisme sur piste
mars masters ce champion d'europe en
2013 il conclut les trophées dans sa
chambre vous allez bien yann très très
bien alors vous n'étiez pas là à la
dernière émission jusqu'à que vous avez
une excuse mais je ne peux pas toujours
me libérer d'accord vous travaillez un
petit peu travaillé plus important que
le sport plus importante que toutes les
attentions wayana vous avez pu être
invité à pour ça on repasse à droite
musique son surnom au l'encyclopédie car
il connaît tout sur tous les sports je
dois me méfier car pour me piquer ma
place basile régolithe avec nous
aujourd'hui donc basile c'est guillaume
a besoin de vous enroulez d un oui il à
côté de vous il a rien préparé pour
cette émission
il a voulu que je mette à côté de lui il
m'a demandé avant l'émission
enfin on termine à gauche il est dans le
rugby depuis une vingtaine d'années il à
ce sport dans le sang une l'entraîneur
de l'équipe senior de plaisir depuis
septembre dernier
il nous fait l'honneur de revenir une
deuxième fois sur ce plateau je veux
bien sûr parler de genlis bonjour eagle
2e et lyon sur ce plateau jouant pareil
vous monter en puissance comme guillaume
on veut bien voir on veut voir c'est
dommage que mustapha soit pas là il
reviendra dans une plongée due il n'y a
pas de monde un petit bonjour à tous cas
on va passer maintenant au programme
d'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du pistard de liquide de france
françois permise du dakar 2016 mais tout
de suite nous allons parler de la
qualification de nantes aux dépens de
menthe en 16e de finale de la coupe de
france
on commence donc cette rubrique
résultats par du football le club de
menthe dernière qui pillent noise encore
en course en coupe de france recevait
nantes une équipe de ligue 1 en 16ème de
finale de la coupe de france donc les
nantais se sont inclinés sur le fil en
encaissant un but en prolongation avec
un but signé alejandro bedoya le score
est donc de 1 0 pour les nantais on
écoute la réaction du fc mantois 78 du
billet suivant on espérait avoir un peu
plus l'espérer les ongles jusqu'au
penalty
sap a été le cas finira demain
d'inattention pour l'europe ça paye cash
ce soir on a été plutôt pas mal
défensivement après comme je disais je
regrette qu'il ait manqué un peu de
folie n'a pas de regret à avoir
je leur avais demandé de
le tout donné je pense qu'ils l'ont fait
jamais
voilà c on a perdu on va voir on va pas
être heureux on a perdu mais voilà faut
relativiser aussi les amis peut-on dire
que le contrat est rempli avec une
défaite en prolongation contre une ligue
1 vous votez votez oui non bon un petit
à petit duel basile wiwa deux d'accord
qui est partagée guillaume pourquoi vous
êtes partagés
juste avant de donner un duel partagé
parce que parce qu'on en veut toujours
plus quoi je trouve que le contraste
certes peut être remplie mais quand on
perd en prolongation je pense qu'on peut
avoir des regrets je trouve que c'est
dommage quoi enfin bon c'est pas
vraiment la question oui ces sirops
contrat rempli mais partagée dans notre
dans le sentiment de se dire que que
c'est rageant quoi donc vous a donné des
idées peut-être pour le duel on va faire
un petit duel entre eux yann et entre
base il ya nouveau commencé pour moi oui
à partir du moment où des faits contre
une équipe qui a plusieurs divisions au
dessus en effet le contrat est rempli
il c'est vrai que les faits d'avoir
emmené quand même jusqu'en prolongation
en plus j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait
eu un but qui leur avait été refusé un
but dans les dernières dernière minute
voilà il aurait pu il aurait pu
justement aller chercher des penaltys et
avoir le même le même succès que
l'équipe qui a sorti lille hier soir
hier après-midi le sac voilà trélissac
donc dommage mais voilà moi je pense
qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait le job qui
sont ils ont réussi à faire parler d'eux
et ben maintenant à eux de reproduire et
de se servir de ces de ces belles
émotions en championnat pour aller
chercher peut-être de beaux résultats et
finir finir une belle d'une belle saison
parce que là ils ont eut ils ont une
comme de belles expériences on passe à
basile vas-y qu'est ce que vous répondez
à yann moix je pense que sa boîte des
joueurs à des joueurs amateurs ça reste
des compétiteurs
quand je vois cette compétition et
surtout un match de foot c'est pour le
gagner
ils s'en sont donné les moyens
maintenant je pense pas que le contrat
est vraiment rempli quand on passe aussi
près de pareil exploit ça peut que
laisser des regrets sur ce match
peut-être sur la gestion de des émotions
du stress de de l'adversaire donc moi je
dirais que le contrat il est pas il pas
totalement totalement rempli quand on
est compétiteur
tant qu'on n'a pas gagné ce match donc
on va vous demander à vous aujourd'hui
c'est de trancher s'il gagne le duel
entre y aller basile mais pour moi ce
que déjà monde le fait
moi je pensais déjà le contrat était de
jambes puisqu'il était déjà parvenu en
16e de finale
c'est historique pour le club je suis la
création d'ici là elle avait 1994 c'est
ce qu'on avait dit de me pour moi pour
moi le contrat a été rempli dans la
mesure où on est déjà pour la première
fois de l'histoire du club is a really
d'accéder à la céder aux seizièmes de
finale pour moi c'était le contrat a été
rempli
après on le sait on pas revenir sur le
débat c'est la magie houle
le fait du sport du football c'est que
l'écart
l'écart peut favoriser et surtout
apparemment l'état du terrain puisque
les on en reparlera les joueurs et après
les joueurs de professionnels de ligue 1
sont plaît pas pas que sur ce match
lorient je crois aussi je lui mais c'est
sur une excuse qui soit là s'ils
souhaitent un petit peu d' excuses ouais
c'est vieux mais pour moi pour en
revenir à quand même à la question pour
moi leur contrat a été rempli c'est vrai
que il y aurait certainement des regrets
des regrets sportivement d'être passé si
près de l'exploit mais après c'est déjà
très bien pour une équipe comme ça dans
les vaisseaux niveau là le contrat est
rempli sur le parcours en coupe de
france et sur le fait qu'ils aient
qu'ils soient allés jusqu'en seizièmes
de finale et qu'ils aient fait parler
d'eux ça c'est clair maintenant sur ce
match je pense qu'on ils ont joué cette
rencontre ils ont préparé pour la gagner
mais bien bonne foi un contrat c'est un
contrat c'est un contrat sur la saison
quand on rencontre comptera sur un match
je pense aussi que disons quand ils sont
entrés sur la coupe de france je pense
qu'ils avaient peut-être pas l'objectif
d'aller jusqu'en cm2 final nous oblige
oubliez le contraire et si moi je prends
ça le contrat pour le club est remplie
en effet pour le club là le résident
fêtard a maintenant pour les joueurs
pensent les joueurs eux-mêmes ils
s'étaient dit maintenant qu'on est là on
va le plus loin possible correction qui
croque un gros comme ça ça doit être un
sacré sens de la fée est bon ils ont
déjà pas l'expérience et y vendre aux
passants acquérir régulièrement
je pense qu'il ya ça qui joue qui joue
dans la dans la balance sur sur les
parce que 105 minutes avant de prendre
un but c'est quand même temps
relativement long donc ça veut dire
qu'ils ont ils ont tenu le plus
longtemps possible mais mais il ya un
moment où d'un voilà les cards l'écart
de niveau il
prend le dessus eh ben ils ont ils ont
joué leur va-tout ils ont joué leur
carte ils ont ils ont eu des occasions
ils n'ont pas su les concrétiser
en effet ils auront des regrets mais ce
qu'il faut au minimum
enfin c'était dimanche voilà pourquoi je
vous ai mis bas justement le truchement
qu'ils ont mal dormi
mardi soir avant-hier soir samedi soir
mais pas du sort le soir du match quoi
parce que voilà qui nantes ou moment
tenante
bah oui les joueurs des moins chez moi
le temps bien sûr qu'on a des regrets
quand on a l'occasion de le faire
maintenant il ya un moment où le
résultat reste logique le regret
peut-être plus grands justement dans ce
type de scénario on va dire parce qu'il
est soutenu jusqu'en prolongation 0
c'est sûr est juste un exploit de et
surpris aussi 45
voilà bien sûr que si le match mais là
dans ce scénario bien sûr qu'ils auront
des regrets maintenant ils ont je pense
sur ce type de match qu'ils ont dû
apprendre et et encaisse acquérir des
ils ont dû apprendre énormément sur ce
match en tout cas mantes a surpris à les
nantais on les écoute nous avons un
super état d'esprit long région donnent
leur maximum
voilà on a un certain moment juste à la
fin on a été en ailleurs un petit peu
changé parce que je crois qu'il boit
nous égaliser mais bon sur le sur
l'avenue du mas était méritée mais
absolument pas surpris par par eux au
contraire des matches comme ça c'est ce
sera face et tous sont difficiles les
coupes sont un sur le show l'excellence
est mauvais c'est très dur on ne peut
pas freiner les charges et élections c
'est déficit à ça on a gagné et c'est ça
l'important
vous disiez guillaume que les mantes et
avait peut-être mal dormi mais les
nantais ont l'air d'avoir également eu
beaucoup de soutien sur cette partie
même si à la qualification et enfin une
tête mal dormi également bon ah non ils
ont la qualité ou qu'ils ont dû se faire
certain élan que l'absence d' âpres
entre le moyen de se faire un peu
remonter les bretelles par peut-être la
séance vidéo ce n'est pas par leur
entraîneur parce que battus 1 0 une
équipe avec autant divisions d'écart
c'est une en prolongation c'est je pense
que l'entraîneur a dû leur mettre une
petite fille qu'il séance mais après les
90 et surtout que sur ce match au soir
de match et là l'objectif pour ces
grosses équipes c'est d'éviter la
navigation parce que minimiser la
fatigue quoi nombreux c'est comme une
défaite pour demander au résultat final
il gagne mais ça pleure desservir aussi
dommage mais pas tous en même temps
géant messieurs plus attaquées menons
pas tout de suite en tout cas j'en lis
quand on est entraîneur comme ça que
d'une équipe de ligue 1 quand on
trébuche enfin on est à la limite de
trébucher contre une équipe justement de
cfa ont réagi comment les commandes dans
le vestiaire
on essaie de les secouer un petit peu
dire que ce n'est pas normal peut-être
c'est compliqué le football moi je sais
pas ça le football parce que c est ce
pas assez compliqué au niveau de la
gestion par tout cas je sais pas ce
rugby experts celui ci que ces
différents jusqu'à l'affrontement en
rugby donc l'affrontement on peut jouer
là dessus et donné des consignes en dix
ans mais il faut accentuer / tél c'était
la zone de jeu il ya l'affrontement au
football signé par l'affrontement la
rose que je voulais dire c'est que quand
même nantes
on a parlé tout à l'heure c'est plein de
l'état du terrain pour des
professionnels
ça peut ça peut niveler niveler les
équipes justement j'en lis on va revenir
juste après sur l'état du terrain
justement on écoute les joueurs les
principaux acteurs du coup du match sur
l'état du terrain le terrain n'a pas
aidé nos joueurs qui vont vite
voire même temps
c'était le même terrain pour les deux
équipes le terreau à sa guise et le
verglas fallait faire conçu avec les
appuis
donc c'est un peu difficile mais on a su
on a su réagir à ces conditions là et
c'est un bon comportement l'état du
terrain avantage les gens misent plutôt
les nantais voulait m'enrôler mentez
est-ce que ça a nivelé peut-être la libé
j'aime aller voter c'est difficile en
termes non mais pour moi ça a favorisé
les locaux on va dire comme ça on va
retrouver ses éléments étaient six à
favoriser ça nivelle les équipes l'état
du terrain ça nivelle les équipes
ce que j'entends c'est pas c'est pas le
terrain en lui-même qui était qui était
compliqué c'était des conditions
climatiques du fait qu'il fasse très
proches ont été gelés que ce soit un
terrain à nantes où a menti lors été
gelée de la même manière et donc du coup
on voit la qualité
ouais enfin toutes ces avantages
l'équipe qui a offert hier forcément
tout à fait t'as fait puisque quand même
là au niveau professionnel et c'est
techniquement et c'est plus précis et je
pense qu'avec ça les embête plus eu
qu'une équipe ça a dénigré du tout
maintenant
dommage que moustapha sow voilà mais
c'est vrai que ça joue un petit peu plus
petit peu moins précis on m'a dit un
petit peu moins techniquement c'est un
petit peu inférieur
c'est le propre c'est le propre des
divas des divisions donc forcément ça
désavantage la plus grosse équipe ça
c'est sûr basile nom qui a l'habitude de
jouer au parc des princes au vélodrome
sur les superbes pelouse ça a pu les
gêner sur 7 c'est sûr que ç'a dû faire
bizarre de se retrouver à mantes la
ville dense dans ce petit stade avec une
seule une seule tribune principale 5500
spectateurs là 5100 spectateurs dont
donc peut-être quoi 3000 ou 2500 la
moitié autour du terrain de boue autour
de la main courante
donc c'est avec c'est une ambiance
particulière dont les nantais avec
quelques cuisantes également il était à
peu près une soixantaine à peu près de
déplacer le match par exemple un cas le
niveau que nantes s'il avait reçu encore
un club de ligue 1 aurait dû être
délocalisé par rapport à l'or au parc ou
ailleurs ont l'impression sera peut-être
à partir duquel des vases il renseignera
pour la prochaine lorsque ira ça dépend
vraiment de chaque stade en fait ça veut
dire que par exemple donner l'exemple
dans le département à versailles
versailles pourrait très bien accueillir
un jour une demi finale dans un quart de
finale de coupe de france
parce qu'au niveau à montbron parce que
niveau sécurité c'est envisageable en
fait c'est qu'il ya des normes fixées
par la fédération pour chaque stade
mantes a dû faire quelques aménagements
pour pouvoir recevoir ce 16e de finale
s'il n'avait pas été fait le match
aurait dû jouer sur un autre terrain
donc c'est pas forcément lié à la
cotisation est de mon éditrice mis
d'argent qu'il fallait non pas parce que
c'était un des sujets aussi virer la
famille d'argent apparemment c'était un
des sujets tabous sur un tableau de
câbles annonce le club très peu à manger
fc mantois c'est un club qui rassemble
c'est la fusion de monclar du club de
mantes-la-jolie de mantes la ville et le
gilet et de bûcher d'accord voilà c'est
la fusion de trois clubs l'on calcule
une ville qui donnent parfois qu'il
n'aide pas qu'à baisser le montant de la
subvention la saison sait pas pourquoi
l'an dernier voilà en tout cas s'il n'y
a plus d'équipé yvelinoise encore en
course donc dans cette coupe de france
il a quand même un joueur qui continuera
l'aventuré enoch quoi thing qui
continuera donc l'aventuré avec le fc
nantes
il avait joué à mantes du coup qui était
son club formateur il était très content
d'ailleurs de revenir sur sur ses terres
on voit justement le voit justement à
l'image basile c'est aussi la force de
vente ce côté un peu formateur il ya
également moussa sow qui est passé par
lille qui a été meilleur buteur du coup
du championnat de france il ya quelques
années de cela c'est ça la force de ce
club si je mange
un mandat il ya un vivier donc
évidemment les jeunes les plus les plus
prometteurs bas intègre ensuite des
centres de formation en tout cas les
clubs professionnels viennent chercher
ces éléments dans en région parisienne
le fc mantois en fait partie donc et
puis cela évidemment moussa sow il a
d'autres il ya une dizaine de jours
qu'il vaut la ligue 1 et ligue 2 yann
m'vila aussi sait pas qui est passé par
les participants dans l'équipe de france
voilà une dizaine une douzaine d'heures
y a pas que moi ton est divulguée
attrapé versailles n'y a pas de
l'abuseur que la versa
il ya un très bon vivier dans le
département et menton fait partie bon
après cette page coupe de france on
passe maintenant la chronique j'aime
j'aime pas de base il a rigolé
notre chroniqueur à basile rigoli le
maradona du sport et binoy nous présente
ces tops et ses flops on commence aussi
par les gemmes jingle j'aime pas j'aime
pas tout de suite mais on commence par
un j'aime pas du coup le jem pas désolé
basilan au programme avant on change un
peu le programme donc le gène jingle
alors basile qu'est-ce que vous n'avez
pas aimé je crois que vous n'avez qu'un
j'aime pas aujourd'hui vous étiez de
très bonne humeur dernier je comprends
pas pourquoi il guillaume se retourne
déjà lancé un je n'aime pas qui
concernait l'équipe de le club de rugby
de versailles qui fait pour moi un
excellent boulot au niveau de la
formation avec les jeunes on le voit
actuellement au niveau du championnat
dans les moins de 18 ans sont selon le
le haut du classement avec six victoires
en huit journées les moins de seize
également sont premiers de leur
championnat sept victoires en huit
matches donc il ya un bon travail
et puis ce le fruit de ce travail fait
pour auprès des jeunes dans ce club ne
ne paye pas ensuite dans les catégories
au dessus dans le groupe senior
malheureusement chaque année il ya
peut-être guillaume 4 5 4 5 jeunes qui
arrivent à intégrer l'équipe première en
fédérale 3 et c'est ça qui est bien
dommageable
donc pour moi il ya il ya des raisons
n'est sûr à versailles il ya d'autres
priorités que le sport et c'est vrai
qu'à arrivé à l'âge de 18 ans une fois
une fois le baccalauréat en poche
beaucoup mais que le r'n'b pop art pour
les études sont en province où mettre le
rugby de côté pour pour d'autres
priorités donc c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment dommageable se trouve que les
dirigeants n'est pas le retour de cet
investissement
à l'heure actuelle vous passer la parole
à guillaume a fait du coup alors comment
expliquez-vous ce fossé ce fossé
il ya un fossé on va dire oui entre les
années passées cette année puisque les
années passées à jouer la qualif pour
les play-offs et là on joue plutôt le
vent joue le maintien carrément
puisqu'on est dernier de poule
voilà donc c'est vrai qu'on fait un bon
travail sur la formation d une grosse
école de rugby avec plus de 160 gamin on
à derna 68 16 avec deux équipes les 200
premières de leurs quatre de leurs
championnats respectifs à toliara
teulière sait on à 68,18 parrein
philiponet une dernier qui sont
deuxièmes de leur poule chacun
respectivement
on a créé une bélascain stan et dont je
m'occupe alors c'est compliqué en
bélascain parce qu'on joue contre des
équipes qui sont qui existe depuis
longtemps nous l'a créée juste donc on
perd souvent pourtant même je leur dirai
mais qu' on a prévu on savait que
c'était comme ça qu'on a on voit que le
fruit du travail qu'on fait leur
bélascain va nous permettre d'avoir des
récupérer dans deux trois ans pas avant
maintenant on sait très bien qu'à
versailles la problématique c'est une
fois qu'ils ont bac pas une fois qu'ils
ont le bac ou nos jeunes ils partent
faire les écoles commerciales il pas de
faire médecine ils partent faire enfin
faire d école d'ingé c'est trop beau
pour les études après c'est vers ça et
c'est dans d'autres clubs c'est pareil
au cir mais je veux dire c'est vrai que
vers ça veut dire que la priorité est
plutôt sur les études que sur le sport
et tant mieux pour eux ce sont les ont
raison on sait très bien que comme le
dit de leurs bases et on a une
génération qui alimente encore les
groupes seniors c'est la junte sont 92
93 qui sont encore jeune puisque c'est
déjà de ses conseillers des seniors iii
ou iv pas plus souvent un quatrième
année et que derrière bas il ya un trou
parce que
parce que ça va pas là les gens voient
quelques-uns dans l'en-tête que
j'entraînais aux plus jeunes qui sont là
il faut dire qu'ils sont à lille qui
sont à qui sont à tous qu'ils sont un
peu partout en france et qui de dons
d'autres clubs profitent du coup bas
après tout ça après tout on n'a qu'un
formateur donc tant mieux pour les
autres clubs mais voilà donc
donc oui c'est compliqué maintenant on
fait le dos rond cette année puis on
espère pour l'instant voilà dernier du
classement je me rappelle de fédérale 3
le maintien va être assez compliqué moi
c'est ce que je disais à mes oreilles
encore si ce qu'ils lisaient dans les
vacances sa dernière mission qu'on avait
fait on n'est pas relevé six points de
retard c'est ça serait allé à voile à
faux courts légal enfin il ya un mythe
championnat a fait rentrer entre les
quatre cinq derniers fayette de champion
dans la poule i à la poule haute ce
qu'on appelle la poutre et quatre cinq
premiers qui vont jouer pour la qualif
et les lie à ce qui est vraiment un
fossé entre le bas de tableau les au
tableau et à nous deux à nous de faire
ce qu'il faut contre les équipes qui
sont devant nous et ça commence dimanche
contre l'as et les b la c voilà moi j'y
crois encore maintenant c'est vrai que
si on perd presque relevé dimanche à des
conflits ça va être compliqué c'est dans
la tête parce que là c'est vraiment une
équipe qui est à notre portée à notre
niveau et donc voilà on en a parlé de dr
fois quand ils sont revenus pour l
entraîneur dans un trailer seigneur qui
disait voilà bah aujourd'hui il faut
admettre qu'on est une équipe de qui
joue le maintien et on va faire le dos
rond prendre deux trois ans va je
m'interromps 2 3 ans en espérant
qu'après le travail qu'on fait sans la
fondation va porter ses fruits et amener
un plus groupe seniors parce que parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a hélas après c'est un
choix politique du classement on n'a pas
le budget pour et faire une formation
forte et faire une forte en tout cas le
plus forte possible et avoir une équipe
première à compétitifs parce que manger
miss me dira pas le contraire mais
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué enfin c'est
compliqué c'est pas forcément simple
d'attirer des joueurs juste avec un
juste avec un beau stade et une belle
bâtisse et ils ont envie d'autres vous
n'avez pas du tout vous la même
situation à plaisir marquons nous
étonnons nous remédions espace est pas
mais on se met le holà
là c'est vrai que bon on ne parle pas
trop trop de l'équipe 2 qui première des
choses
la chaise d'être premiers actuellement
donc je me suis arrêté ça y est on a la
chance d'être premier les raisons il y
avait besoin de parler un petit peu
nous on a la chance d'être premiers
actuellement
il joue le maintien mais c'est surtout
joué revenir sur sur les jeunes qui
montent d'un enseignant certes
et ça c'est le propre de tous les clubs
il y en a qui partent pour les études
son avocat puis à versailles il y en a
partout mais il ya surtout un autre
phénomène c'est que est ce que les
équipes de jeunes évoluent à un niveau
assez important pour permettre
d'alimenter sportivement et efficacement
les équipes seniors du club
lorsque la quasi exemple à leur disais
il enregistre quatre cinq joueurs qui
évoluent en première j'aurais tendance à
dire que c'est énorme
owona mais tu as raison c'est énorme si
c'est le cas c'est ça m'étonnerait quand
même geste mais je pense qu'il a une
mauvaise info ou qui sait mais c'est
plat de thé avec ses fiches
mais la fin de l'été mais c'est énorme
parce que s'il n'y en a qu'un ah ouais
déjà cette année qui joue en première
voilà voilà voilà généralement ces
juniors qui montent et alimente l'équipe
au laser parce qu'il faut qu'il
s'aguerrisse et il ya eu l'idée voilà
créé la bulle à ce qu'un mécénat
bélascain est battue peut être un carton
c'est donc toujours sur mustapha y voilà
comme je disais tout à l'heure
mustapha sort de ce corps voilà donc on
va passer maintenant à jaime basile
jingle ce que vous avez aimé basile
alors un gem pour l'équipe masculine de
handball de plaisir actuellement
deuxième du championnat de prénationale
donc le niveau le plus long sur le sur
le plan régional les plaisirs oies sont
allés gagner ce week-end chez nos amis
versailles et d' alexandre taillefer
31-30 il n'est pas présent également
présents aujourd'hui pour débriefer la
rencontre il faut savoir que ça fait
trois ans que plaisir essaye de monter
en nationale 3 3 ans qu'ils échouent
pour un rien l'an dernier ça s'est joué
au goal avérage
donc voilà on espère on peut espérer que
ce n'est cette année sera la bonne moi
j'ai envie d'y croire même si je pense
que que notre ami alexandre partageaient
pas forcément c'est la vie s'il était
présent aujourd'hui
surtout il a perdu 3 2 grâce à deux buts
à domicile
vous êtes d'accord j'en lis il faut
jamais perdre espoir même quand on finit
2eme 3eme pendant des années des années
ah oui mais c'est que jamais perdre
espoir jamais jamais il faut bien qu'un
jour ça sourit puis la salle harbin
sourire comme j'aime qu un coupé qui
jouent aux billes et gardien de but de
plaisir je suis content pour lui il
ajouté sans avoir à partir du moment où
je termine deuxième il qu'une chose
c'est que ça motive pour enchaîner les
suivantes est allé chercher la gagne la
gagne après donc bien sûr qu'il faut il
faut se il faut le tout servir de ces
expériences pour ne pas commettre les
mêmes erreurs
donc on continue on continue maintenant
avec vous basile donc votre deuxième
jeune mais j'aime
il concerne le dakar 2016 jingle alors
oui un gem pour nos deux pilotes
yvelinois dont on avait parlé
jean pierre garcin et jean-philippe
theuriau qui était présent sur le rallye
raid du dakar contrat rempli pour eux
déjà parce qu'ils sont ils ont réussi à
aller au bout de cette épreuve sachant
que c'était une vision 2016 vraiment
très difficile beaucoup d'abandon des
courses en montagne à plus de 4000
mètres d'altitude je crois dès qu'on dit
à l'homme qui a eu des problèmes des
conditions météorologiques très
difficiles durant la première semaine
et puis aussi au niveau en terme de
résultat de classement une 32e place
pour pour jean pierre garcin une 40e
pour jean-philippe theuriau donc c'était
l'objectif dans les objectifs qu'ils
s'étaient fixés
yann c déjà à l'exploit de terminer à la
course au delà du résultat sportif
ils ont terminé au delà la 30e place où
je pense me disais que la victoire
je pense que quand on offre que ce faire
un dakar un jour c'est quelque chose qui
me soit entre énormément tout à fait
même pas peut-être un rallye plus petit
mais ces enquêtes
mais non mais non j'adore j'adore le
sport automobile et donc c'est vrai que
participer à ce genre de genre de chose
doit être très très sympa pour pour
l'expérience
en effet je pense que quand on prend le
départ de ce type d'épreuve on sait très
bien que quand on est amateur voilà on
veut juste finir prendre du plaisir voir
des beaux paysages voir faire du buzz
pas du tourisme puisque puisque c'est
pas du tout l'objectif mais voir voilà
voir des pays d'une manière différente
et en effet si le voilà l'objectif était
d'aller au bout ils sont allés y sont
allés au bout ils ont dû avoir quelques
galères à certains moments j'imagine
puisque ça se fait pas ça se fait
rarement rarement dans la facilité mais
met donc voilà je pense qu'ils ont dû
prendre énormément de plaisir et qui
reviennent avec des souvenirs plein la
tête
donc au delà du résultat sportif au delà
du résultat sportif maintenant est-ce
qu'ils y retournent est ce qu ils le
font régulièrement et bien là après
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut voir
parce que question d'argent bien sûr
mais c'est vrai que quand on est à
l'expérience aux fleurs
toujours ancré dans les lacs à cette dix
septième partie donc peut-être que quand
on a autant d'expérience peut-être que
finalement lui se voit là c'est plus un
amateur c'est plus un poireau comme on
peut les appeler dans le dans la dans
les motos mais mais peut-être qu'il a
envie d'aller
de faire peut-être qu'ils aient envie de
faire mieux et donc voilà maintenant
c'est beau de pouvoir être arrivé au
bout de quinze jours 2
quinze jours de rallye comme ça là
l'opinion bio que yann d'accord et que
yahoo il a parlé de mon temps d'enlever
les gêne pas laisser certains j'aime oui
tout à fait très bref
donc on passe au dernier j'ai donc de
base il rigole il concerne le cyclisme
sur piste et la belle performance du
trappistes benjamin temps va tout à fait
nous tout le monde sait qu'il ya quatre
appuis un très bon club de foot
mustapha nous le confirme régulièrement
en revanche peu de personnes savent
qu'il ya également un jeune spécialiste
de sic et sur piste très prometteur il
s'appelle donc benjamin thomas il a 20
ans c'est un des benjamins de l'équipe
de france qui s'entraîne donc
quotidiennement au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines benjamins i là
il a brillé de mille feux ce week-end
lors de la coupe du monde de hong kong
en remportant deux épreuves le scratch
et la course aux points
donc voilà deux des résultats qui sont
très bonne augure à un mois et demi du
championnat du monde est un rendez vous
mondial où laura je pense une carte à
jouer pour une éventuelle sélection dans
tout cas des points marqués pour une
éventuelle sélection pour les jeux
olympiques je crois que c'est par
équipes sur sur la poursuite par équipes
donc à suivre
yann je me tourne encore une fois faveur
vous c'est notre spécialiste cyclisme
c'est pour moi oui est-ce que c'est par
thomas c'est le futur je crois que j'en
dis ça parce qu'il ne connaît pas
c'est le futur c'est 7 de cette
génération
les épreuves de coupe du monde pour moi
c'est jamais jamais très très révélateur
surtout pour surtout dans le cyclisme
sur piste
c'est j'ai regardé la l'idée d'un
désengager il y avait une quinzaine de
gares seulement sur une sur le scratch
ou la course à points je me souviens
plus donc voila c'était pas ce n'était
pas un très très haut ou un très très
gros plateau maintenant voilà s'il
arrive à confirmer aux championnats du
monde fin février dans à la fin février
là on pourra dire qu'il a maintenant
c'est pas un inconnu
benjamin fait partie fait partie des de
la nouvelle génération y en a
quelques-uns qui vont qui vont qui vont
pousser encore derrière la relève dans
tout l'est dans tous ses défenseurs
sébastien vigion vitesse
avec je vais en genre être un autre
moment voilà sébastien vigion en vitesse
est un jeune junior senior 1re année qui
va qui a été vice champion du monde du
signor en juniors 1
il s'est raté en juniors 2 j'ai pas eu
toutes les informations mais voilà ces
ratés en juniors 2 mais voilà ce sont
des jeunes qui rentrent en équipe de
france et qui vont qui vont très
rapidement à l'époque fédération belge
est tout à fait une belle d'une heure
sont plus tard donc moi je souhaite que
benjamin ouais on avait décru quand même
en été mais une assez forte sans son pit
tout à fait tout ça fait très régulier
très régulièrement il ya déjà des
nouveaux qui arrivent fassions une belle
belle formation à beaucoup un bon suivi
un bon
une bonne continuité voilà il est
maintenant j'attends j'attends ça
février pour voir les stats championnat
du monde est bon on en reparlera donc
voilà on s'est reparlé sport voilà fin
prêt désire donc après cette rubrique
j'aime j'aime pas de base et rigoler on
passe maintenant notre focus du jour il
concerne les jeux olympiques 2016
aujourd'hui notre focus concerne le
cyclisme sur piste et un homme en
particulier françois pervis le pistard
qui habite à quelques mètres de nos
studios à montigny-le-bretonneux sera
sans doute l'une des têtes d'affiché de
la délégation tricolore avec cinq titres
mondiaux remportés ces deux dernières
années le cycliste sur évidemment l'un
des favoris pour remporter une médaille
à rio l'été prochain c'est son objectif
nous l'avons interrogé à ce sujet pour
vous ça représente quoi les jeux
olympiques ça représente le gras quand
on est champion olympique
on change cc
c'est interplanétaire c'est c'est
quasiment indescriptible parce que là là
ça me fait sortir de l'anonymat pour un
sport comme le mien qui est pas
forcément très très connu et puis on
n'est pas connue que seulement des
cyclistes dans le monde entier on est
connu de toute la population mondiale
quand tu es champion olympique et tu pas
sur toutes les télés du monde
le pistard françois pervis et il a plus
grandes chances de médailles
ça y est vous vouliez contre moi à la
peau tellement le pistard françois
pervis et si la plus grande chance de
médaille yvelinoise avant de répondre à
la question je vous rappelle les noms
des différents yvelinois qui devront
partir aux jo sauf pépins physiques il y
aura tout d'abord tenir yoka le boxeur
de 23 ans a terminé 9e des jeux
olympiques de londres en 2012 est
également devenu champion du monde de
boxe amateur à doigts en 2015 c'est sans
doute un prétendant à la victoire finale
les renseigner oui bon il parait il peut
y voir avec un gros avec un gros
désavantage vous mais c'est continuer
les niches convention il ya ensuite
l'autre pistard de l'équipe de france
grégory baugé il est à 30 ans neuf fois
champion du monde donc de cyclisme sur
piste médaille d'argent aux jeux
olympiques y sera avec françois pervis
l'une des têtes d'affiché de la
délégation tricolore
on aura également au gie aux acides de
guillard qui a remporté la médaille d'or
à de la coupe du monde 2015 en pologne
qui a été médaille d'or en équipe en
2013 en chine à 32 ans sera sans doute
sa dernière chance de remporter un titre
olympique et à lui effacé son zéro
pointé à londres en 2012
en football deux joueuses du psg
pourrait gagner une médaille avec
l'équipe de france les bleus sont
aujourd'hui considéré comme l'un des mis
l'une des meilleures sélections
mondiales avec le japon l'allemagne et
les états unis
enfin en atom à baruch en aviron le
sportif de 28 ans originaire du chéné
est licencié au cercle nautique de
versailles n'a pas encore remporté de
médaille aux jeux il a décroché déjà
deux médailles de bronze aux
championnats du monde avec une médaille
de bronze en 2015 en france
quand je vous énumère du coup ces
champions françois pervis est il
toujours la meilleure chance de médaille
yvelinoise je continue par vous du coup
en botte malaisie la meilleure la
meilleure vous êtes partagés
non pas la meilleure l'une des meilleure
des chances
la rue des chasseurs à part le boxeur
qui pour moi voilà part avec un handicap
non c'est un petit duel yann contre eux
aller guillaume riou l'avant par rapport
aux partis qui je pense n'a
malheureusement a juste un drapeau
tricolore derrière lui qui va faire qui
pourra pas perdre à qui va perdre parce
que ben les juges vont vont l'allumé
comme comme ils ont pu faire avec nos
autres nos autres combattants les
éditions précédentes donc la ja voilà
lui c'est lui je pense que c'est mort
tous les autres vraiment ce sont des
sports où les oules acquis ou la nacion
ou là où la france est généralement très
forte et où sont des sports ou là ou là
où ces disciplines elle vous apporte
beaucoup de médailles
donc ben
l'escrimé elle est déjà championne du
monde donc oui bien sûr qu'elle peut
qu'elle peut être quelques allers
simples dames par équipes n'ont même pas
tant qu'on n'est pas dans son duel
voilà et en plus il sait par équipe
voilà vraiment des chances de médaille
maintenant voilà moi là où je vais
défendre françois c'est que françois il
est quand même championne du monde des
deux dernières années sur plusieurs
plusieurs disciplines pour moi françois
doit revenir de riz de rio avec le titre
de champion olympique en keirin
je vois pas d'autres possibilités
surtout qu'il est quand même cette année
beaucoup plus confiance que ce qu'il n'a
été l'année dernière pour les
championnats du monde donc le niveau de
préparation n'est pas du tout de même il
sent bien qu'il n'a pas eu tous les
pépins physiques qu'il a pu avoir
l'année dernière je pense que françois
va être très très motivé pour revenir
avec une médaille et je le vois pas
revenir sans titre je vous passe la
parole dit je vois là il a pris quelques
longueurs d'avancé dans laquelle deux
longueurs non il a dit qu'en fait qu'il
était d'accord avec vous simplement pour
moi françois il devrait ramener un titre
non mais on parler de la question
c'était la plus grosse
ils sont tous faux argent bronze
non mais la plus grande chance de
médaille je suis pas une des chances de
médailles parce que pour moi les autres
athlètes que tu as cités sont aussi
capables de garder la part de médailles
sauf en effet le boxeur il ya vraiment
une voilà on sait jamais la box n'a
jamais cessé loyal ou pas faim les juges
sont ou pas voilà après astrid que je
connais très bien
bon cette année c'est que en individuel
donc c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
mes boss pour ça depuis des années et
voilà
faute d'y arriver les joueuses de foot
en effet le foot comme dirait mostafa le
foot pratiqué par les femmes
et bah je pense qu'on est aussi
largement une charge de médailles on est
quand même dans les meilleures nations
voilà thomas bach ou qui viennent
d'avoir une médaille de bronze au choix
du monde donc il en plaine en pleine
bourre enfin mais qui sont tous des
chances potence blessures que les
cyclistes sur piste enfin français sont
quoi qu'il arrive toute façon quasiment
toutes les chances de médailles
puisqu'on est une nation forte même si à
londres on s'est fait filmer die il a
fallu l'arrivée
les anglais ne fallait pas lier par
exemple les parlers la grande-bretagne
pardon excusez moi mais pour moi vrai
ils sont tous et toutes des sports où on
exclut ces petites d'avoir des médailles
donc c'est pas la plus grosse blague
pour moi c'est une des chances de
médaille je repense à grégory baugé
grieg bouger s'il revient encore avec
une et d'argent mais
il fallait être très très très très très
déçu il était déjà très très déçu à
londres la cmm pas envisageable pour lui
quoi dont l'arrivée en france
en france il y reviendra mais c'est sûr
pour moi il arrêtera sa carrière
là-dessus c'est enfin bon et jacques
passera quatre ans selon les cas et 4
ans c'est trop long
mais la façon dont il a gagné toute
vitesse au championnat du monde à 51
d'année dernière et voilà il a hélas il
l'a montré il a dit vous moi cette année
je vais gagner
il a gagné en 2015 léhady maintenant
pour moi il ya plus qu'un truc qui
compte c'est riou donc faire l'impasse
sur les championnats du monde qui vont
se dérouler à londres
messieurs et là je vais dans les mêmes
mains coupées aujourd'hui un pour moi
grégory sera pas champion du monde
fébrile et mise tout sur les jeux
olympiques dans la saison tout sur le
jeux olympiques il en a ils crient
gorille n'en a rien à faire d'un titre
de champion du monde en 2016 il ya qu un
truc qui compte pour lui ce sera dépensé
confiant comme beaucoup des jeux
championnats du monde je dois passer au
second plan
donc cette année cette année il y aura
qu les jeux olympiques y compte et rien
d'autre basile qui gagne dans ce duel
entre guillaume et et jan françois
pervis ces personnes l'autre ça sera lui
on aura plus grandes chances de
médailles yvelinoise
cette liste que vous avez cités je
rajouterais également une jeune fille
demande
haby niaré 20 ans championne du monde de
taekwondo en 2015 donc il fera également
partie des grandes chances de médailles
attribuées 2016 est encore un sport où
la france en taekwondo intègre une
médaille quoi voilà donc faudra compter
sur elle également je pense ici ici ces
gens qui sont dans les yvelines en plus
il n'y a aucune raison qui reste à yahvé
de l'oisans rigby à 7 dans l'équipe de
france mais c'est aussi une chanteuse
lyrique des recettes les féminines plus
que je sais pas s'il ya pénurie noise
qui traîne de ses deux sites on se
renseigne raffermissent pour vous qui
est ce que françois pervis sera titré je
veux pas prendre jusqu'à dix ans et
c'est quand même le spécialiste
il a fait une bonne synthèse je pense
que tout ce qui a été citée ce sont des
disciplines dans lesquelles on a
l'habitude de ramener des médailles et
safran foot oui même foot c'est ouais
c'est tout nouveau ce que c'est tout
nouveau donc ne sait sur qui parier pas
derrière puisque c'est la première fois
même si dans les autres se sont que des
disciplines où on a l'habitude quand
même dans les détails dont je pars
ajouter autre chose mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qui c'est guillaume keim qui
avait raison parce que lui dit qu'il est
content du filament
je crois que c'est la place qui veut ça
en clôture ce thème par notre jeu le
dilemme avec françois pervis schering
champion olympique
piste à saint quentin en yvelines
à la moyenne au rugby à khazani rousseau
jany vous a surpris
non pas du tout j'étais en train de
prédire à toutes ces réponses que je
connais je le connais bien françois
et en effet je pense que j'aurais pu
répondre pour lui et j'aurai fait 100 %
peut-être juste sur cali j'aurais eu un
doute parce qu'il a pris trois titres
alors qu'il n'a pris que deux à saint
quentin
mais c'est vrai que prendre des titres à
la maison ça a été quelque chose
d'énorme pour les on passe à présent à
notre rubrique débats
notre débat concerne de sport très
apprécié dans les yvelines et par nos
chroniqueurs le cyclisme et le rugby
sportif on a des clubs donc qui sont en
fédérale 3 les qui vendent la 5e
division française comme plaisir cheveau
encore versailles et maisons-laffitte
on a également une dizaine de clubs bien
placé dans les divisions inférieures en
cyclisme la le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le paris-nice
qui passe par les yvelines la question
est simple les yvelines sont elles une
terre de rugby ou une terre de cyclisme
voter vert pour vert pour cyclistes bon
je vous passe je vous fais ça parole
genlis genlis allez-y donc pourquoi les
ennemis sont une terre de rugby pour
vous parce que déjà shutter de plaisir
et puis c'est une bonne raison je
rajouterais quand même que des clubs que
vous avez cités vous à vous lire ou y
qui était en yvelines aussi et qui est
un fédérale 3 et qui est je crois que
quatrième de poule 1 de sa poule 1 qui
gaze ça fait un club de plus par rapport
aux six films c'est un club de plus dans
sa pesée tri mais sinon c'est compliqué
aussi de comparer un sport collectif
tels que le rugby un sport individuel
tels que le cyclisme c'est assez
compliqué forcément le rugby draine un
petit peu plus de monde ne serait-ce que
au niveau du public je pense que au
niveau du public au que d'ailleurs
cyclisme mais surtout au niveau des
sentiers au niveau du licencié mais
encore une fois c'est le propre du sport
collectif sport le sport collectif
après on est ce qu'on voit beaucoup plus
de monde dans les stades sur les dix
matches sur les stades de rugby
ou sur les courses de deux vélos dans le
coin ça j'ai pas la réponse
moi je prêche pour ma paroisse c'est
pour ça tout simplement un débat comme
celui là on peut le faire oui mais non
mais en termes d'événementiel nationaux
en tout cas une nationale pardon je
pense que c'est qu'il se met supérieur
au rugby dans les yvelines parce qu'il
ya le gall paris daniel paris nice il ya
des conventions il a dû manger
normalement
originaire a maintenant en termes de
sport médiatique départementale vraiment
je pense que rugby supérieur après le
vélo ça que je suis là plein qui en font
mais bon je aller vous promener aller
parrainer malheureusement dans le
dimanche matin dans la vallée de
chevreuse
il faut pas le faire quoi ma route
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont changés cyclistes
donc je sais que du monde
voilà donc le cyclisme enfin les
yvelines une terre de cyclisme
oui même le paris nice par ben part de
50 de paris paris brest paris tous les
quatre ans par de saint quentin en
yvelines
donc non c'est vrai qu' on ne se rend
pas compte du nombre de personnes qui
peuvent pratiquer le vélo en venant tout
à l'heure sur saint-quentin j'ai doublé
un cycliste un cycliste à m'écraser
n'ont ils pas une tare long parce qu'il
fait froid quand même amplement
mais voilà d'après c'est pareil quand
j'entends les effectifs du club de
versailles en rugby c'est vrai que c'est
quand même assez impressionnant le
nombre de le nombre de coureurs ce qui
est sûr c'est que le club jour deux
joueurs ce qui est sûr c'est qu'au club
de versailles vélo il ya moins de
courant voilà donc le cyclisme n'est pas
non plus un sport qui va être un petit
peu de pain c'est une activité qui peut
pratiquer sans faire de sport
moi je fais la différence entre activité
physique et sport allait faire du vélo
le dimanche même si vous faites du vélo
et 100 150 km tous les dimanches vous
faites du vélo faire du cyclisme c'est à
l'aide crochet un dossard et aller faire
une compétition et quand on fait du
rugby dans un club on va faire des
matches tous les dimanches où tous les
week-ends et là en fait on éveille là on
va vraiment faire un sport parce que il
ya les spiegel il ya l'aspect
compétition chose que dans le vélo on ne
va pas retrouver donc c'est plus un côté
amateur peut-être en vélo pour vous moi
j'étais l'eau ait été prise il va y
avoir un côté plaisir et la colère côté
loisirs dans l'eau il ya beaucoup moins
de compétition de moins en moins de
compétiteurs en cyclisme
chaque année il ya plus accessible par
contre c'est vrai que vous allez vous
allez chez décathlon vous sortez avec
votre vélo vous allez faire pas de
marque
allez vous pouvez citer go sport et puis
voyant 4 3 3
à sport voilà mes donc que vous sortez
de votre vélo vous pouvez aller faire
allez faire votre balade tous les
dimanches et vous pouvez aller des
rapidement montés sur des grandes
distances 100 km en vélo on pense que
c'est énorme alors que c'est rien alors
qu'un match de rugby
non mais pour tout le monde je veux dire
du futur m on est sur la scène comme on
est vraiment ce média n'a pas les mêmes
effets silence que les sacs basile
étrangères si vous voulez mais quand on
parle souvent que j'étais le seul qui
soit 9 quand on parle de cyclisme
rien que sur ce plateau à chaque
émission c'est évidemment comme on le
disait pour des événements d'ampleur
nationale ou internationale où des
spécialistes de la piste en équipe de
france mais rarement voire quasiment
jamais sur des épreuves locales qui sont
organisés je crois que cette année au
calendrier il y avait un cyclo-cross si
je me trompe à aucune épreuve inscrite
du dépendant le département
malheureusement fait ya très peu dans
l'organisation dans le département pour
le cyclisme surtout il n'y a pas de
béquille peut vraiment compétitive en
dn1 une équipe il ya l'équipe de l'armée
terre qui est une équipe ariane était un
peu particulier mais voilà aujourd'hui
les meilleurs jeunes du département qui
sont dans les clubs de chalon citer
quelques-uns mais maurepas elancourt
conflent ensuite dès qu'ils sont au
dessus du lot partent régulièrement dans
d'autres structures en région parisienne
pour pouvoir percer au niveau
compétition il ya encore du travail je
pense à faire dans le cyclisme sport et
encore même dans la région ile-de-france
de toute façon on a quand même une
problématique au niveau au niveau suivi
d'aider des jeunes
beaucoup de jeunes sont obligés de
partir dans l'oise sur nolwenn
nogent-sur-oise valeur après en vendée
en vendait parce que c'est là qu'ils ont
des vraies possibilités d'accession à un
niveau professionnel alors quand ils en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines on
n'a plus rien quoi donc pour moi le
rugby c'est la terre c'est le sud ouest
la région et puis le vélo c'est la
bretagne est d'accord au niveau du
public qui draine le plus de monde entre
le cyclisme et le rugby selon pas
comparer un événement local le matin
quand les compétitions internationales
qui ont même une compétition quand on a
fait le gros plus de vélizy où on arrive
quand même être 1000 1500 personnes dans
le vélodrome c'est pas c'est pas rien
c'est pense pas qu'il ya quelques flops
championnats départementaux ces plats
régionaux et départementaux mes
championnats régionaux mais il n'y a pas
de communication
donc à partir de là en effet il ne faut
pas lire il ya personne aidant les
personnes dans les tribunes mais mais ça
c'est pas c'est pas l'aiguillé c'est pas
un club qui organise ces en corse et des
instances fédérales
le comité régional et donc l'appartement
ait pas de communication les gens
viennent parce qu'on a c'est qu'elles
n'ont par exemple pas plaisir il ya
énormément public par exemple du public
géologique mais là pas mixer ça
viendrait force se donner des coups
c'est oublier les degrés voilà mais il
ya quand même plus de mal aujourd'hui
d'organiser ce week-end que depuis deux
rencontres de rugby que deux courses de
vélo donc sur sur ce qu'on veut vraiment
je pense que c'est largement devant
quand on appartient plus qu'elle de
france qui passe
on voit bien une étape du tour de france
qui passe dans le département dans la
vallée de chevreuse rambouillet le
départ qu'on a vu il y a du monde des
deux côtés de la route surtout surtout
ne parle tout le temps sur tout le
parcours paris-nice moi j'étais agrément
surpris du nombre de personnes qui
veulent voir les spectateurs qu'il peut
y avoir sur le champ le premier thème
haïti
donc il n'y aura pas de vainqueur entre
le rugby nice
on passe maintenant à notre défi les
jours
le défi concerne aujourd'hui le rugby
les joueurs du sky rugby doivent toucher
une bouteille en faisant une passe de 15
m soit on ne te pince il ne touche pas
la bouteille
ils sont éliminés on regarde la séquence
je vous lis mon collège vient d'orange
josquin et rugby demi de mêlée et surnom
tout le petit rien tocqueville jeunes
lévis a non juste à côté
mon poste et demi de mêlée aux cayes
rugby et et mon surnom c'est eux qui
brille cela derrière je joue au rugby
parmi elles vous habite à guyancourt et
cartons man au pire j'ai une voix dans
le bretonneux nouvelle qui marco mathys
bonne megal j'habite à coignières jeu
sans trop sky rugby et mon surnom c'est
la mer noire
on
beau vainqueur en finale il ya eu un peu
de sous pression c'est un peu difficile
mais il a fini par l'emporter ouais
c'est un petit junior qui vient
s'entraîner avec nous aujourd'hui et qui
a mis à l'amendé
tous les seniors donc bravo à lui
beaucoup de fierté beaucoup de fierté
mais je pense que au fond de moi il ya
eu un peu la chance du débutant
et puis j'espère pas me faire frapper
ensuite dans les vestiaires pour cette
victoire qui a été mérité de bout en
bout
genlis une réaction sur ce je sais
comment j'ai vu qu'ils le gagnent à
lille et apollinaire appelé dire on va
le regretter
c'est bien de nous les montrer du
recrutement c'est vrai c'est pas si les
portails sont pas tous réussis non mais
je vais bien venet bien bernar venet à
versailles voix plaisir qu'on rigole
aussi un peu connus ou pas c'est une
attente jouer peut-être que plaisir donc
patent joueuse qui joue le haut de
tableau vous la montée c'est un jeu
c'est pas très gentil mais nous nous
venons de faire des pour revenir aux
gagnants et une belle passe ça c'est
vrai c'est le remercie vous voyez donc
on conviendra avec une petite bouteille
d'eau 3 à 8,5
on passe maintenant aux coups de gueule
d'arnaud le witch
notre chroniqueur arnaud le gouïc pousse
à chaque émission un coup de gueule sur
le sport dans le département aujourd'hui
arnaud va nous parler des disciplines
alternative je vous laisse la parole à
arnaud
merci michael donc mon coup de gueule du
jour va pas beaucoup plaire à monsieur
larbaoui représentants des sports de
masse que sont le football et le rugby
pour ne prendre que
fournisseur officiel de purges
télévisuelle et moi aujourd'hui je vais
me faire l'avocat des sports alternatifs
des sports urbains et sports extrêmes on
les appelle comme on veut des sports
dans lesquels les français réussissent
plutôt bien
et qui sont spectaculaires contrairement
à des 0-0 de vie gang ou des tôles face
aux all-blacks un monsieur neyreneuf
tout ça pour dire que en surf on à
jérémy florès qui est plutôt bon en
freestyle motocross tom pagès qui vient
de finir deuxièmes des red bull
x-fighters excusez moi
c'est là une des plus grandes
compétitions de freestyle motocross
kevin rolland ski halfpipe qui cartonne
et pour faire dans le local on est
antoine bizet en vtt free ride donc
c'est un versailles et vtt free ride
c'est plutôt de la montagne mais ça
n'empêche pas de participer aux red bull
rampage qui est la plus grosse
compétition de la discipline qui s'est
déroulée dans l'utah aux états unis il
ya quelques quelques semaines
d'ailleurs ça va pas trop bien marché
pour lui c'est pété le bras mais c'est
pas grave c'est un bon gars ce mec il va
aller loin
tout ça pour dire que en france et dans
les yvelines
on manque de tout emballement à la fois
médiatique et aussi de structures pour
pratiquer ces sports
mon chez nous on va pas faire du surf
mais prendre les skate park par exemple
ce que font les mairies en général c'est
des tout petits trucs riquiqui avec
trois modules qui du coup attire pas les
jeunes attirent pas les pratiques en
matière pas les associations on ne peut
pas créer deux clubs
et voilà donc c'est comme ça qu'un
enfant ne décolle pas pour finir sur une
note un petit peu positive on va prendre
l'exemple de rambouillet 15 p un skate
parc attractif qui par le biais de la
mjc le met en valeur avec des formations
pour les jeunes ça crée un vrai sport ça
devient plus juste une discipline
alternative un peu grippé et c'est vers
ça qu'il faut tendre c'est mon avis êtes
vous d'accord avec arnaud le goïc on est
passés les sports alternatifs à se
développer
vous votez oui non je remplisse chercher
que j'ai alors genre miss contre basile
balle et vasil janvier son conseil à
toulouse aujourd'hui ce commencer
comment sait on a vu qu elle s'est jetée
comme l'investissement on est pas assez
les sports alternatifs à se développer
dans les yvelines on est même en général
certainement mais voilà je moi je veux
tu as à dire bon il y a tellement et
telemann de sport c'est ça c'est vrai
avec est-ce que tu as mis les spurs
voila voila je vais dire il y en a
tellement qu'on n'aide pas c'est le
sport en règle générale est que ce soit
on parle et on parlait des aides des
municipalités il faut savoir qu'en mai
avec les budgets de plus en plus et de
plus en plus restreint et ce sont les
budgets qui sont en bas qui sont
diminués dans les clubs de sport avec
général alors c'est vrai que on a déjà
du mal à faire vivre les sports
médiatique entre guillemets on parle et
à leur rugby cyclisme il ya le football
qui est toujours le sport numéro 1 en
france donc on a déjà du mal à faire
marcher ccc discipline n'a alors les
sports mineurs
c'est encore plus compliqué bien sûr
qu'on les aide pas mais il ya des
priorités c'est comme tout il ya des
priorités
malheureusement il ya des priorités
alors je vois les skate
quand j'étais jeune je skate on le
faisait c'était pour rigoler c'était
pour s'amuser
c'est devenu une discipline à part
entière je sais bien je l'entends mais
il ya des priorités pour moi ya des
priorités et serait qu'on les aide pas
assez vasile mais je suis d'accord rage
à abidjan
après oui on est dans priorité c'est sur
les disciplines des jeux olympiques les
sports les plus pratiqués en termes de
en terme de licenciés ça c'est vrai que
je suis bien d'accord avec ça et je
pense que des disciplines comme comme le
roller le skate ne font pas partie des
priorités
trèbes où il ya moins de pratiquants
je sais
wemmel été champion de roller d'ailleurs
je crois bien du tout lui fait tout de
vitesse sport
11 et ford et les coûts de mort
alternatif ouest sport méconnu mais mais
c'est pareil je veux dire on a en france
on a des champions du monde de roller de
vitesse tous les ans tous les ans tous
les ans tous les ans c'est une équipe
c'est une très très grosse équipe
non maintenant ils migrent vers la
patinage de sur glace pour pouvoir mais
un championnat du monde un champion du
monde de roller de vitesse c'est juste
quelque chose de l'ultra spectaculaire
mais j'imagine bien mais c'est
complètement enfin on entendrait parler
coiffant ne va jamais je disais tout à
l'heure ils se mêlent sur ne pas le
citer que red bull qui feinte la marque
à deux boutiques qui favorise ces sports
là avec parce que c'est leur image de
marque et ses racines en alors dans leur
douleur comme plan de communication mais
à part ça il ya une fin c'est on va
jamais la télé sauf si on a la chaîne
extreme sports où je sais pas quoi là
mais non mais c'est s'est clarifiée
machin enfin céline et moi j'ai incité
beaucoup de marque red bull on va parler
de bugs cucquois là mais non mais bon
j'imagine jjg regardez donc les gammes
sont désertiques ans a passé sur
eurosport mais c'était un pur bonheur
donc si on fait la crise n'arrive
finalement la répartition de l'argent
les subventions etc est répartie en
fonction de la médiatisation du sport
non mais a pu gagner plus d'argent à
répartir de toute façon aujourd'hui déjà
dans le sport dans le sport en général
c'est la débrouille
même les sports connu mais la cc66 est
devenu c'est ça devient catastrophique
pour bien sûr et puis alors après dans
les yvelines pour des sports extrêmes
enfin pour un gars que faire du vtt de
descente je pense que il n'ya pas de
tellement tellement les infrastructures
ouais ben on fait vite on fait vite la
montée décembre par rapport à une
montagne donc rihanna qui fait du relais
à voir dans la vallée de chevreuse
voyage à l'image en tête c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve le jeudi 4 février pour
un nouveau numéro de six ans par les
sports à bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures sportives